[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
oh yeah
uh 15 minutes what's going on guys can
you hear me fine all right I'm gonna pop
in with this uh reaction thing real
quick tell me if you guys like the way
this looks we did this for the for a
direct but I don't know if you guys are
gonna like it so I did stretch it just a
little bit over over here if you guys
could see
uh but if you guys want it like regular
you know uh uh aspect like just tell me
and we'll we'll try both because right
now we're pretty much just watching this
to what you guys want to watch so uh you
know tell me what you guys think
and um we will go from there if you guys
want to change this up a little bit I'm
quiet it's probably because the mute uh
the mute the music should be gone Craig
maybe you should turn up your your
volume does anyone else see someone says
loud and clear someone says quiet I'm
confused man
skew
regular better okay
hold on
let me just delete it
and re-put it back out
because if you guys want it like regular
aspect that's fine I I don't care
uh hold up
uh it's it's not um they can't hear you
yeah it's right now the desktop audio is
muted
no they just scare me that's all
[Music]
I blew us up just so they could see key
wild see this is this is what you guys
don't see because King be playing uh
copyrighted music when he pops in
laughs
that's why I don't care how it looks
guys it's just whatever you guys want
like it doesn't matter to me how it
looks
thank you
all right all right all right let me
unmute you guys now
all right yeah
we couldn't do that for the copyright
jump
but if anybody wanna know what I was
listening to
um
is King Von I'm on your ass
go pull that up go listen to this
and go figure it out while I was going
crazy yeah
[Music]
house flan said that King is mute oh he
shouldn't be muted anymore they're
they're too far back on the on the
stream mic check might check make sure
everybody can hear us yes sir so it said
keep listening to the Nickelback it's a
Nickelback oh
you're ridiculous
hey Alex said King can you link your
Spotify playlist absolutely
um yeah
that Spotify playlist Mike your family
might not like you
yo listen man I love my brother J dub
man I love my face
these dudes don't understand like that's
why I'm telling dudes that's my comrade
game is the gamers bro and um yeah I
posted that joint y'all I know y'all
guys is wilding out I don't care that
it's not um multiplayer I'm just telling
people from the beginning
that because everybody was going crazy
when they saw it and like oh it's gonna
be multiplayer and then I thought about
it I was like that might distract away
from The Narrative of the game that's
exactly what happened because I seen
dudes talking about if it's not done in
this way or that way I ain't gonna buy
it I'm like wait wait wait wait wait
wait
how you gonna say you're not gonna play
it and you're not gonna buy it you
already
establishing that if it's not the
traditional Spider-Man that you used to
that you don't like it I'm like let
these dudes do what they do they
professionals they they big boys if the
game is good it's going to get his
Praises if it's bad then hey they gonna
get they knocked but yeah sometime man
we we don't want change and I get it you
know you can't force everybody to to you
know but you got to think about it from
this perspective Jay it's like okay so
you got the first Spider-Man 2018 right
yeah then you got the Miles Morales both
same formula when they saw both of them
on the screen just like myself I was
ignorant to assume that it'd be Co-op
right and and then you started doing
combo moves and stuff like that and your
mind started going crazy
yo so for some people they thought it
was a natural progression because not
right or wrong 2018 is PlayStation 4. 20
uh Miles Morales PlayStation 4. you know
now we had a PlayStation 5. the
expectations is through the roof a lot
bigger yeah right you don't have those
constraints right so I don't know he
said he's just gonna be coming in hot
yeah it's just I don't know I can hear
the argument and I can understand things
but always remember guys sometimes when
we ask for change and then we get the
change then we gonna [__] about the
change after the change show up
you know because dudes wanted Halo to be
a certain way and 343 listen to y'all
and did the change yep and then the
change came oh this ain't feeling like
Halo all this I don't like this oh I
it's too sporadic you it's too open
world I wanted to go back to how it was
so it's you know it's the Yin Yang Yang
it's it's it's you can't please I'll be
honest you know I'll be honest sometimes
you can't listen to English you have to
know your product know what you want and
deliver that product and the game is
going to be better because if you listen
to Gamers man I feel like y'all that's
one of the issues 34 3 had they kept
changing off what the community one
instead of holding their guns and make
what they wanted
343 is a prime example the old heads of
Halo they wanted it like the original
Halo Halo one two and three but then you
got
the natural progression like King was
saying the dudes are going to want to
have to get with the modern crowd right
you want to you want to bring some of
the Call of Duty religions and the
fortnite news in you want to bring the
new people in you just can't cater to
the old heads you know and so it's I get
it it's a hard position to be in if
you're developing games but you got to
know you're going to turn off the old
heads why they ain't gonna like you but
then you might you you might not pull in
the people that you need from the others
trying to go get like you're chasing the
carrot Chase to carry it you lose your
your identity yeah so absolutely no
um no game know your product know what
you do yeah I've seen a single person
game it's kind of like like Sony right I
know people say well why don't they do
this one today listen they thrive on the
single player
story driven over the shoulders that
really changed though remember yeah that
wasn't yeah that wasn't their identity
you know and I know their identity with
Sony the house of ideas yeah right you
walk in and you you was playing so many
different games like you wouldn't got
pop around for the rapper or um jumping
flash or or ape Escape all these these
wild ideas that they were going in
Gravity Rush stuff like that yeah that
the ideas has been shrinking and
shrinking so that's why I can see why
stray gets nominated uh because even
though that's not their game that's
their style yeah right yeah so if it
fits in there in their culture yeah
that's the type of games that they
design yeah no you're right
and stuff like that I gotta address the
rum real quick guys so how obviously
me and Incognito we're gonna be in La
next month we're still gonna have the
reaction I have kid smooth coming off
the sideline to like do all my part so
uh kids movie will be hosting uh uh
that's not next weekend no next month
yeah next month all right so Ken Smith
will be here with King and solve and you
know whoever King and solve it I get
you're invited Jada because we always
have a thing if if you come into the
lion's den for for your show you have
every right to come in for our show that
you already know you know
well listen it's it's first of all
we all like-minded sometimes people get
caught up in that toxic Twitter stuff
and don't really understand things how
how it really is presented so you know
um the behind the scenes we all mess
with each other
um
and even up front I don't care I've
never said nothing disrespectful to Jay
um I never said anything disrespectful
for a lot of people I don't care this is
a game but everybody's welcome at all
times
this is just open form this is fun this
is gonna be a celebration because I'm
going to be spending cash here I'm a
PlayStation now uh service owner so I
will be seeing what's coming into my
service
question guys
put a one in the chat if you think we're
gonna see one of those games of service
one of those 20 games of service that
Jim was talking about today one of those
new IPS
and um
real quick someone says what do they
open the show with I'm saying Spiderman
too
yeah
no
you close this Spider-Man too
Snake Eater they open with Snake Eater
it could be something like that
oh wait they open with Snake Eater
a bunch of ones I don't remember what
the one it meant but bunch of ones
if they show one of the games of service
that's that's the question
cut it up
we I will see
um
they will they will end with something
they will open with something
I'm gonna be honest it's what's in
between that's going to make a
difference
yeah the PlayStation VR stuff
yeah I'm gonna show some VR stuff I hope
that they don't spend too much too much
time just announce Half-Life Alex get up
out of there
um I wonder if we're gonna see the
handheld
swalla
all right go ahead go ahead go ahead all
right we got a five dollars
uh for Nintendo Dawn yeah that's what I
like man we got Nintendo people up in
here we got yeah they ain't got nothing
to play after tears of the Kingdom
uh games we'll find out after the show
and that's so he's pretty much saying he
he predicts 40 of this to bvr 30 to be
third party games and we'll find out
after the show it's coming to Xbox and
PC and 20 money hat exclusives and 10
first party that stuff's the only
formula that we got now
put the crest in the chat for uh uh
Craig
hooligan appreciate you welcome welcome
to the welcome to the realm man welcome
to the realm hello Chris stay stay tuned
here we come two dollars you can try
from Jax 82 what about the trailers from
wayfinder and two dollar Superstar from
Alex King and I need you to wake me up
when I fall asleep
I got you oh man I got you man I I hope
you don't fall asleep
um in this one I mean I I think they're
gonna be doing some stuff I hope so guys
listen
they waited two years I think this was
the January show that I was hearing
about and they held it back and you know
they gotta show this stuff because they
got to start promoting certain things
um
I really think they're gonna have a good
one I really think so I mean I think
this might be the show that shows me if
I get a PlayStation VR and we we got
almost 400 people in the chat hit that
like button guys let's get that over a
hundred likes I know there's 20 of you
in that chat right now they ain't hit
that like button actually you want to
get techno there's like 320. we ain't
getting tactical in this [__]
uh shout out to Craig cool again for he
gifted one uh uh one IOP I gifted a
round membership to things
Lord metro'd worry about your master
sword King tell you that the kingdom is
Game of the Year oh man listen
um
it's gonna be game of the decade for you
hey hey
Real Talk would it be some tears of the
Kingdom Spider-Man 2 Final Fantasy 16
and Starfield are are competing for game
of the year that means there's some for
everybody I don't think Final Fantasy is
there
um I think star field is there I think
tears of the kingdom is there I think
Spiderman is there and I think it's
gonna be a wild card uh indie game
that's gonna pop yeah
it could be Hogwarts could be I haven't
played Hogwarts to be honest it's okay
oh yeah
Final Fantasy 16 is huge I hope what can
we call it yo I hope uh Jedi survivor
man let's let's not walk past that
because Jedi Fallen order missed the cut
by a couple of months I think those uh
those issues that had gonna have hurted
a little bit Yeah
selling my Xbox now appreciate that man
appreciate that go go sell it right now
um
listen I told you yes hell yeah we
holding the line I I told y'all you
don't have to tell somebody you leaving
just leave the club trust me we having
fun we won't look at that man I asked
for a hundred you guys gave me 150. now
I'm gonna be greedy I want 200.
well we got 445 people in this chat
there's there's definitely walk in my
door wipe your feet on the floor make
sure you hit that button
can they just walking up in your
business without wiping they they get
mud all over the floors oh no you gotta
stop at that door and you put your feet
on that Welcome Matt and you wipe your
feet off and you hit that doorbell bing
bing let me know you here if you can't
stand up and be accounted for I think
you sneaking in here
don't sneak in here hit that button and
and
be a subscriber oh yo listen console
that we giving away it could be a
PlayStation 5 it could be whatever the
hell that you want but make sure that
you're a patreon member all right I'm
letting y'all know now there we go we're
starting it up we got we got a two
dollars from phase one four days gone
PS5 remake [__] it all right muting
myself Jada what up
what up my brother what's going on
Christmas time it's Christmas
are you on Twitch King
hell yes we have fun twitch I'm going to
Twitch
yeah it Twitches ahead we got to go to
you already acting up
oh I just accidentally uh gameplay sorry
guys give me a second
stream up
that's it right there
it is a VR game so just bear with me a
second car accidentally exit it out I'm
still not seeing it I'm still not seeing
it oh look crazy
sorry about that guys
oh
that's not it stop it it beats hard
it'll be nice
CGI CGI
why they can't be the gameplay kick yo
believe it oh man shut up
oh man
[Music]
I feel red full energy
y'all ask for multiplayer games
exactly
fair game fair game kidash
take it to you make it that's right you
made it haven oh that's good you would
have picked up yeah hey hey Jada that
was a CGI I'm just wanting to point that
out yeah yeah we know we know we know
they said they said it's on the screen
this
day they ain't trying to hide that hey
yeah they said this is not
representative of anything questions of
the chat do you guys like the way the
the reaction is hi everyone
president and CEO of Sony interactive
that's ever happened
what's next for PlayStation 5. now until
the third year of the life cycle of PS5
and we've been fortunate to have so many
fan favorite titles released on the
platform what's even more exciting is
the developers you're scratching the
surface of what's possible gaming
experiences I thought I was muted today
you'll get a glimpse into some of the
most breathtaking and imaginative
content that will be coming to PS5 and
Playstation VR2 and now what you've what
about now enjoy the show
enjoyable you say yeah that was a
throwaway [__] it's over
all right well let me grab these real
quick
oh
look familiar
also like these are happening all over
the Galaxy right this is XCOM 3.
next
Christmas
decision of your life to get your money
prove to yourself that you have the
strength and the courage to love me
join the hell divers
I mean PlayStation 5. yourself
they are in trouble they're starting off
with this y'all better cook yeah
they won PC
over here man
thank you
[Music]
hey what's that game they did just
released that um
the
Japanese game where they do spells in
his first person
um ghostwire yeah it looks like ghost
wire but it's like a higher ground it's
like a vow it looks like a vow oh there
you know how PlayStation do we got a new
skin
[Music]
when it first came out yummy
wow
whoa
anybody want a candy fish to go with
this wonderful disaster show
[Music]
everybody
this will smell Sony exclusive
this looks like like a bloodborne type
of game yeah I think I think somebody
sent me this one this might be a DLC to
that uh
I think PlayStation
uh marketing right
I mean Xbox
okay okay
but if it is
feeling the main protagonist I'm feeling
all of it
you see the move
look at them so wave moving and did he
did that Double Split joint yes you know
I like that oh look at this metal arm oh
oh he got the Hat beat oh he's playing
guilty yeah this is the attic game I
would love it but this is the attic here
[Music]
this this feels like no this is
Xbox
One it might be a day one y'all
promote we put it on
Yo they got a lot of that right there
that best King and James I'm fighting on
Medicare
Boys on Twitter yeah I'm riding horse
from animations looking good I love the
wall running yes the traversing is good
yeah
it's definitely looking 60 y'all we
don't know you know
oh
back up yes
crazy as long as it's running you know
we got people that need to play that we
have 600 people hit that like button
guys let's get that about 300. subscribe
subscribe right now yes I'm gonna show
you something that you've never seen
before Oh hey that combat
play
Phantom Blade who make this zero Phantom
play zeros
that means it's for everyone Tom Brady
games
[Laughter]
still got more fun with my heart back
one this is where they lost the show
that's fine I mean yeah it's coming for
everybody
yes five you know 505 with us they ride
with us
we like this stuff pause
oh now this is a PlayStation exclusive
don't go move
this right here I'm into PS5 this is
only on Playstation 5. we good y'all
keep this absolutely yeah yeah the
powerful is this is y'all this is y'all
we look on Twitter and see if Aaron
Gerber announced that Phantom Blade on
it
even though even though the next one
came to Xbox too because
[Music]
last time I spoke earlier
I won
the line
oh man
lovely art style though
I don't know what that boy's standing on
though
standing on business
you should slide
come into PlayStation 5. here we go all
right Dr that's the only exclusive stuff
for this show I guess
yeah we got 310 likes man we got 614
people when you hit that like button I
know this more people know here we go
there we go
400 stuff
I'm a robot
who's the studio so we know the studio
tell it all
[Music]
said um
so much would be possible
[Music]
if we believed if we still have
faith
that follows
yo this is for everyone this is an e for
everyone's included to the party
do you really think you know Sony's the
same I don't know King
hahaha
[Music]
just their version of everyone everyone
oh man
Sony what happened to you bro
[Music]
I'm about to go off right now my man
Sony what's up bro
what's going on Sony
oh bro
hey this is like a little bit better
picture me right
they're fighting like lomachenko
[__] you're giving rounds away champ
come on stiff upper lip
I didn't give it rounds
put your best foot forward champ
yes I chose Sony come on man
uh yeah
this sure looks like a day one in the
service thing eh yeah I hear you guys uh
YouTube's having some issues with the
the Stream
yeah Sony's having an issue with their
stream as well
streaming there are 690
000 people you said never
it's not my it's not my internet my
internet's gone I'm looking at it
[Music]
remember this moment
I feel you if something new to all right
we're gonna remember these moments
right now
yeah yo everybody get kitty they trying
to get the game pass out the way they're
trying to entice them because
they go to the big boys
kitty cat quarter everybody get kitty
cat Corner oh man come pick up your tabs
all right all right what's this what's
this come on another multiple
going on
definitely for PlayStation oh um this is
probably the next part of Final Fantasy
yeah the next part for Final Fantasy
yeah this rebirth yeah I look different
though you like whole new game or it
might be the throwaway game that
everybody get like look like a PVP kind
of situation
this looks like it gets shut down
it's very overwatchy this is something
complete [__] on him
if Xbox
you two games behind yeah YouTube is uh
yeah
I'm watching on Twitter
[Music]
okay now you see the game okay now it
looks like a PlayStation game now we see
this looks like a like a weird take on
platoon
hey I'm not gonna tell you who just
texted me but listen this is some Xbox
level showcases
[Music]
Splatoon at home I'm done
oh my God it came to life oh the world
looks beautiful day
[Music]
they stealing something from Minecraft
now
[Music]
this is
why I'm here if y'all know listen
remember what I said go listen to King
Von
um
on it wait wait wait hold on
PC you know
we're from cheese King what this is e
for Africa yes
this is the best this this y'all doing
better than I thought y'all
yo I told you when I tell y'all to hold
the line you just sit back and hold that
line
you're for you're free to leave anytime
bro he holding the line it ain't over I
told you they were gonna show a whole
bunch
when are you gonna pick up the reins and
hold the line because he's doing it you
waited two years
the Xbox killers are coming just hold on
they're tearing down the PlayStation 5.
no no listen they went after the game
pass problem now they going after the
Minecraft crowd this year
they dropped that through the ceiling
like it was a banger
actually
[Laughter]
not
absolutely no this is this is dead frog
Odyssey
hey hey it kind of looked like that
this show can't be more than a b
yo here here come the alligator
alligator gonna bite him oh yeah
[Music]
to get them and they're fighting
games
this is actually a good game
y'all too far ahead for everything
refresh your Twitch you'll refresh no
y'all y'all don't switch yeah we're
gonna twitch get on Twitch
okay there we go
[__] there we go there we go you know
that for everybody though
that cat been lit out the bag a long
time ago
Metal Gear we here we got one one game
that I asked
this is what you've been asking for huh
yeah I know I know it's coming for Xbox
Metal Gear Solid hey that's two dollar
two trap from Corey JW about to act like
he have an internet
y'all ask for it yeah we have to eat
that snake over there on Xbox two
players
I'm into PlayStation 5 and everyone else
switch 2024. I can't wait
collection sneak back into the original
games
not Sam Fisher uh uh Solid Snake in
there like twitch he's twerking on the
streets for everyone here we go captured
on PC
okay what's this
oh my God
they got the original games
right here how are you liking the stream
Jay dog
[Music]
oh man I think I'm building simulator
when they say they want a diverse
they diversing boy oh
fly yo they got breath of the wild
they're breath of the wild here we go
[Music]
this looks good though yeah
not Jay I'm with you
[Music]
with you
is this
I don't know
no it's for everybody's next
we want to know is it in game man Final
Fantasy 16.
I hear the music these people live with
a knife this assassins
that giant crystal
that didn't look Assassin's Creed like
no square
my girlfriend
this is Final Fantasy again yeah
didn't they give a whole showcase to
this yeah and if they probably should
announce the demo yeah hopefully get the
date today
you better hope so see it's starting to
show this show is off
hey card I told you Keith was gonna
crackers
we still got a half hour yo we got 369
likes with 660 people in there hit that
like button
like going on a blind date she don't
show up no it's like going on a blind
date and she show up dressed up a heart
doesn't like this I know he don't he
can't get it oh Final Fantasy okay I
know you said he rated his ass
boy they are showing a lot of it I'm
surprised they're showing too much of
this we already had a whole string that
we did there
[Music]
it's syncing this show and not raising
this show well what I'm concerned about
is if they're shorted here how much more
new stuff are you I want the exactly the
Final Fantasy is huge like huge
absolutely huge absolutely June 22nd
worldwide come on come on I didn't want
to see that hair today be real I was
hoping yo they didn't show you nothing
like this all we got folks it's okay
if
it's okay
oh Silent Hill Into Darkness Silent Hill
epic games Epic Games like epic games
it's right up your alley
oh I like her she's a good actress
that's AI special agent Robert epic
games epic games
this is a remake to Alan what's that
remake
now the kids if this is no it's not this
is this is a big Xbox game
oh that's a homegirl from The Wire yeah
I told you yeah you're right
good actress
dead oh you like it you're like it was
you ain't played on the 360. look at how
she looks
this was this was its own but you know
what king at the end of the day this is
still eighth right this is for everyone
yeah I mean we don't know we don't know
hey I'm liking I'm liking it
easy now we asked for this
right but this ain't the same story
though this is like Ellen White
this will reimagine
hold up the fact that even though that
that's for everyone it's still big that
they do yeah
Assassin's Creed another E for everyone
this show is rated but that shows that
shows you a lot though
if they got the marketing to all of
these games what does that that's kind
of say though that Microsoft has come
with it since they got nothing of Their
Own
no that's that's saying right that's I
mean think about it it's like Hogwarts
Lacy Legacy that's the face of that
product like where is
already got this I'm trying to figure
out where that is
just keep waiting it's gonna take away
man I've been waiting for two years for
this show and this show showed up and
it's all it's this form this is not the
Sony I know man listen we know you're
gonna get your redfall DLC
yeah but it's a new game though
you got to try to win
yeah
this is the one the Mirage that's going
back on to this yeah
this look good oh white Twisted okay
there we go five
[Music]
do they God knows I heard they was in
the store available
you just saw those sales reports out
there yeah I saw the numbers I saw them
they selling them why can't they get
games for them
they're
breaking hearts
the dudes is watching right now and
saying not like this like King all I'm
all I'm gonna tell you is Phil has
spoken
he said I see you soon he said y'all
don't turn him to the dark side and I
don't this is the third cat game I've
seen today
yo you stupid
he said play with kitty cats together
coming to the PlayStation 5 and the
PlayStation 4. we're gonna have the
PlayStation 4 wait here to be fair
straight was a goatee Contender oh yeah
this is true ain't not that I didn't
vote for it wait it didn't win
games okay games VR let's see what we
got let's see uh this is probably a
Services game or it's very uh Chronicles
like
it looked good
this is good good RPG action now you
know the these these are for those
x-plants out there if you're looking at
jrpg field
[Music]
s
you know what's crazy if they don't say
these types of games right here just
just a crowd for them they just love
dudes and they they love these type of
things man they'll love it on Xbox too
if it's Xbox only if it's in game pass
because we don't want to pay for this
yeah
that was the more
y'all heard what David Jackson said
that's right if it ain't in Game Pass
that's why God award have been Game Pass
day one with him
online
[Music]
I'm I'm allergic to this showcase
got everybody sick it's handing out Kobe
this is for everybody God come on Sony
give me something for me
another game but it's for everybody yo
yo I told y'all what I told y'all was
gonna happen on Wednesday
undefeated let me go get my championship
belt five dollars from JD Gamers so far
I've seen Minecraft with too many tears
at the Kingdom knockoffs out on the way
too and I thought would look better I am
excited about assassins
oh this is
Tony right
sorry
can't hold the line
yo if anybody know what want to know
what I'm eating I'm eating Swedish Fish
it's called Tails because the tales of
this story it's deep for everyone
oh my God they have wasted a whole hour
of our life
yo this is going down in history
and they think they're gonna do it like
last time you don't remember the last
time because dudes are following me
because I was like oh God of War is not
gonna be there God it was not gonna be
there
Spider-Man
this show would be a hard three for
violence
let's go
[Music]
when you go looking for strength
not like a game two dollars you've got
from Sharon keys
oh man it must be hard being a
PlayStation dude right now
right now y'all was capping so hard
y'all still ain't get to the VR portion
they might close the show I ain't got to
be a whole portion you just do it here
we go VR here we go here we go this
isn't VR
VR
they are it might be praise be the VR
gods
hey hey people that uh Phil promised us
Xbox games
136 people in here hit that like button
man
we could do that you guys in that chat
got the power
that's in um that's 2D and we got one
useful huh Hades
um it's for Xbox only
um they needed to get a copy of that
game too remember they made part two of
it and it was uh the little surprise
this isn't what I would want at like a
kind of show this look like it's at a
steam event this is a steam game come on
man stop it don't cap for them like oh
wait wait this is probably one of these
things too yeah it is everything this
whole show was going fast
we was wrong we're so [__]
it's right
Spiderman unless they show like three or
four really good games like
I'm very disappointed right now I'm so
underwhelmed
like James you waited two years for this
listen I waited all 2022 for Xbox game
and I didn't get it so all right look at
the difference
I'm gonna get my Captain America shield
here we go here we go here we go
near automata too
mm-hmm
yeah autonomous two dollars per shot
from DJ bird J dub face looks like we're
the one thing go where's that one thing
uh two dollars from Death slide Street
Fighter running on uh as their servers
and two dollars to drop from Lou
Morningstar this looks like there's
something about card money yo
um I'm gonna tell you this guys and
don't do it don't go ahead
um
for the simple fact unlike a lot of
people's CEOs he's showing up
he's out here so just give me a fantasy
star vibes
that's the first thing I was gonna say
it looks like I think they just they may
have [__] relaxed
this look like um
filled with it looks nice to the super
shot from Jack 82 King was right this
shows it's trash two years for this I
told guys ahead of time
hmm
oh oh I like it and a water inside okay
I like it I don't care
you know what it is King when they go in
the water it's like it's like a cut
scene to wherever the water is please
don't leave them bro what's this yo that
game is gonna be so everywhere they
didn't even tell you it's only for them
let's go cap call let's go come on okay
what's this monster hunter DLC
no Horizon evil Dogma
too
that's a huge game
that's huge that's for everybody people
been begging for this yeah
Microsoft does need to work on getting
more of these I like more of these
marketing deals
spend your money
this is huge all the brothers here for
Necromancer what what even yeah
he was able to make one before remember
what even is this show for besides aw2
and Metal Gear Solid there's been
nothing it's for everybody
the show is e for everyone this is the
all new inclusive song
they saw the deal go down with ABK and
was like yo we got to switch up
five dollars from traffic Gary this is
what happens when you lose call
a message
you gave me keep up the great work guys
Dogma this is going to be huge yeah
everyone it's gonna be great I think
they got a bit I think they had an
exclusivity first hey not actual
gameplay this whole Show's been saying
on PC not actual gameplay it's not here
for everyone this is a Five Nights at
Freddy's
VR titles now we in the VR Zone
all you Xbox dudes is watching this what
I told you hold alive
get the t-shirts right now in the merch
though you're walking with the finals
hit that like subscribe and share it out
also we give it a console away so if you
like anything that you see here you can
play it anywhere pick a console the game
yeah
help wanted
[Music]
you know pixel bit G what I will say is
it's sad that I can read super chats so
crazy
to get the crowd up they're gonna do 10
minutes of Spider-Man
it's gonna show out would it show up
it's gonna show up yeah baby Fargo
VR2
[Music]
it's like
he said he said if y'all rocking with me
I'm rocking with you
it looks good though
yeah yo it's the same thing so what
y'all need to do is go spend five six
hundred dollars for VR and then y'all
could add that to your PlayStation and
there you go there you have it
absolutely absolutely no game passes
the VR sexy King is right not actual
gameplay again we are in the weeds you
think they're gonna end with Spider-Man
yeah yep it's looking like that's gonna
be the one more thing if they end with
fight it better be hold up it better be
Spider-Man and end with something else
something else
the most disappointing show I've ever
seen
one more time
gameplay
I think
yep okay and this is not even that
actual gameplay I'd love to sit here all
day and chew your ear on the road again
you know what I noticed King is how
quiet Jada
first person
can't believe what the hell is going on
I got no faith looking at these bangers
yo I want to bring Charlotte back I'm a
VR I'm a VR guy hashtag get Sean
put it towards the end I told you coz
[Music]
all right 10 minutes let's get it
Spiderman it's a wrap it's done Hail
Mary Spidey
I need two we need two things to really
all right let's get all those videos VR
Target
this is Def Loop the extra mix
[Laughter]
from Corey team JW looks like he
watching General Hospital
yo come on guys don't don't go at the
guests
I know I know I know you know we just
don't do that over there you know
being cool as hell he don't need to show
up and you know Jada always been a real
one yes he's real he on camera too
not like your favorite YouTuber hiding
behind the beep beeps
come on now behave yourself yeah
King this is this is now the biggest
opening for Xbox w
ow
these PlayStation Twitter spaces fixing
to be a cinema
no I'm liking the manipulation this is
what I had to do yeah I'm thirsty man
I'm thirsty but clearly PlayStation they
ain't settling that thirst I had to go
get some pop-ups
biscuits for everyone this one is fire
because you got
um
Corey J dab knows it's all I'm a wish
wishlist
yeah synapse look good yeah July 4th
also on um
they not bringing that man
[Music]
so it's available now today go get it
right now don't break your legs running
through the door to go cop that
come on
VR too y'all ain't got psvr I got it not
actual gameplay I didn't see gameplay
actual on this show at all well you know
why right because I know they can't show
you VR on a 2d experience you can't
you're not gonna get the same so I know
I'm done with it I know yo
it's time for them to Showcase it is it
in the same Destinies like Universe
maybe and it may be like a PVP kind of
focus but
we're gonna I'm not 100 sure it's in the
dusty Universe because this is
definitely the separate game that
bundle's been working on this is
supposed to be a multi-plot too yeah
only thing that's not coming to
um XBox is Spider-Man
we'll get a shot that's every
PlayStation Fanboy right
it's nice laid out
I'm turning the putty
oh it's stealing oh they're acting the
hardware hey some of that sound though
yeah oh that's all it sounds bad
that's it
[Music]
the whole show
five minutes it's Gotta Be Spidey oh no
fighting it's over hour not actual
gameplay Destiny now
it's Destiny yeah
what I told y'all money had maybe final
shape
we flame gods
Vanquish nightmares
on Sunday it has felt below to six
[Music]
oh is that key
y'all
me too kiddo come back but hey let's go
I'm here now for everyone
they did yeah
August wait August to the showcase on
August 22nd
not actual gameplay not actual gameplay
not actual gameplay
calm it out what's up with this
PlayStation not showing gameplay
nothing has been gameplay what's up I
believe they're bringing cake hey gotta
go to the well I can't believe that only
stops for the last one literally
Bungie's carrying this whole show I
can't believe that's the highest talking
point of this show here we go
mom what's that
just give me that Elysium vibes
like the show didn't show nothing
stupid
wait I know that ain't it will you read
that um
um yalen B five dollars to the chat no
game playing on multiply thank you guys
for letting us watch JW looks sad
where's Wolverine and anything there
ain't no Wolverine coming this show was
uh it's got a new Spiderman congrats
reasonable
okay
is the Victorious
they actually make Grant's reasonable
interesting it's based on a real life
story well I mean I'm just mad that they
show it in here at the game show but
this the movie I'm gonna watch the game
this all day oh my God I mean we know
I need a drink
drinking
I don't like movies oh you're showing
movies baby they diversifying their
portfolio baby
they're showing you something different
that you never saw before
you are so messy
850 people in the chat hit that like
button let's get those likes to 500 man
you wanted to see gameplay well we got
an actual movie we we we sitting here
Spiderman wait you gotta hit it thank
you for joining us today final game
before we get into it okay here we go
come on who you sign somebody an Ice
Station Innovation is our passion what
they do and that applies to not just
what games you play but how you play
them later this year we will launch a
dedicated house enables you to stream
any game the handheld Here We Go Remote
Play a PlayStation
I got one coming to my house for free
I can't believe it I can't believe that
they showed them
in the near future I'm also pleased
[Music]
hey I'm Gonna Cancel my uh
yeah
all right I don't like the fact that if
this look like two dual sets together
it don't matter let's get to this Spider
Man
Spiderman man oh man
this is Wolverine no blood cause the
blood Wolverine this is Wolverine
think so yeah this is Wolverine who you
think this is craving or something they
can't use craving
this is Wolverine why was Spider-Man be
in a job I heard this I heard the admit
to him
this is cool
oh
this is
craving that's crazy that is this is
Spiderman it was Spiderman then we're
craving hunters in it yeah I'm supposed
to say why would Spiderman yeah
don't say the release date out loud it's
a real handheld versus that thing
what they don't want you to
what they don't allow you to say the
release date no no they just so that the
chat sees it when it pops up okay and
one of us don't ruin it is what you find
sir
perhaps don't do that
and there's no cap I didn't even buy
that streaming black cat yeah you know I
got a steam games
but then what you call it I mean I would
say self-esteem to keep your access and
and get that with the steam deck Murray
like the facts
the great hunts begins
foreign
a bit nervous because they didn't show
gameplay for a game that's coming out
soon
release date
six months later six months later
no I told you the words
I thought after you know after the other
handhelds that night would just be like
nah that was that thing is already in
production
it's a streaming machine
but if you can link it to your PS5 and
just play all your games on the go maybe
in Show gameplay now
what you want it all right now
oh this looks good
we already know
is it Co-op no they've already announced
dude the way he's talking I feel like
crazy
foreign
I'm on it sounds like crazy
noise
not actual gameplay
it's gonna probably be my Game of the
Year this is sorry tears of the Kingdom
this is gonna probably be my Game of the
Year y'all know how I rock a Spiderman
between miles and Peter are going to
have with him having that uh Venom
switch off
me
oh all right a little tight walk so
different the difference between the two
yeah
because on fortnite right now if you
play with Miles and you use his web
shooters it's a whole lot faster than
this
I love this part you remember you're
speaking to the Joint yeah
oh
dude this is what I'm talking about
where are you guys that's what I'm
playing in September alongside a uh star
field
why miles look like he got cheeks though
he got a BBL what happened
um
[Music]
[Laughter]
thrustmaster pause
what are you fighting
somebody just smacked them in the back
of his head spidey sense ain't go off so
we've seen craving yes sir the vulture
gotta be yeah yeah that's a vulture
I was gonna say that when he knocked the
little uh
drones picking up lizards Trail
he's still eating lizard we can catch
him off guard the lizard
dinky get behind me
the whole snake skin yep it gotta be the
lizard
yep he molted he's just just again so
it's the first one had all those
villains the second one
Elizabeth
hey man any threads the building's
swarming with Hunters any sign of
Connors uh yeah Yankees tracking him hey
Mr Parker
Mr Spider-Man I mean hmm
but the date isn't complete
I think I got a lot wait me too
that wasn't me me neither
I don't even have a stomach so that's
let's go
oh they're gonna show a fight with both
of them all right
that's what I think is pretty similar to
the original Spider-Man
this this license
I can't wait to watch it again in the 4K
by the FBI Drive
right now
but see this is what I don't like about
crazy crazy
Squad help the doorbell right I've got
the metals
nope switching
no this is on you
[Applause]
no time
I like the fact that they show that he's
not using weapons
no no Spider-Man is good defenses
Spider-Man hang on
[Music]
whoa
oh the lizard's under the water
there you go
remember
[Music]
it's right behind you I know I know yo
this is this is
man
this is Game of the Year
coming over my game yes
okay foreign
I can't
and one of them remember bro that's it
hey alley you from three hi
yo they're gonna sell a truck from the
statue bro
[Music]
18.
I did I thought at was just an average
game
he got away from us
it's good Pete
I saved the tracker
let's go man before he gets too far no
he's doing the most with that suit
the fact that they work close with Sonia
Sony has the IP that they able to take
certain liberties with the costumes it
works very well never like that
yeah so there's going to be back and
forth between the release date let's see
the release date
[Applause]
[Music]
oh they moved off for September
no I still think big star field outside
big stars where else would they put it
oh they don't they ain't got nothing
else coming out this year
wherever you're going to maximize the
dollars I don't think September this
time
a magnet
you still can't believe
I can't believe this show is a three
so real quick uh let me turn this down a
little bit unlike get these super chats
because I already missed a couple of
them guys I'm sorry two dollars from
chat from uh Nintendo dominiotaku I'm
liking this Spiderman
Corey Tidwell miles
okay
they try to catch me slip through that
two dogs will be trapped from shroom
Kingdom my husband eats pistachios so uh
because salads
two dollars from Jeff from free R Kelly
it ain't looking good for you keys
man you better sit out I don't know if
you got cataracts
one one three eight uh Spider-Man 2 qte
movie experience
you'll miss me
that's why they showed you the movie
before DJ bird where's all my frauds
that sold their series X
yo they still you can go back and get it
right now
it doesn't she she's gonna be there and
we're gonna happen
I'm gonna tell you I give it a seven out
of ten yeah but but because I ain't
gonna lie Spiderman say Spiderman
Snake Eater yeah those those there
gave it a six for me and what gave it
the extra the extra point was the fact
that they they showed I'm a big VR dude
and they just show me they showed me my
VR stuff but I'ma tell you I am a little
disappointed because the expectation no
I'm gonna tell you why because
expectation for this show
was to show up and show out of all of
their first party stuff yeah the only
first party stuff that they really
showed was the new smaller teams that
they got like the I guess the the other
stuff but like Naughty Dog where are you
at with your stuff no no faction listen
listen listen right oh yo what's up with
the faction with Naughty Dog what's up
with their other game they're working on
Corey ball Rock right with Sony Santa
Monica is working on something else we
know um all the other Studios so I'm
like
yeah
where are where are all of these games
where where is that stuff so I was again
I never tempered my expectation y'all
see me on Twitter I'm always never your
expectation no matter what you get I
don't care if it's state of play I don't
care what it is never lower your
expectation you a gamer you should
always expect the team the dudes to go
out there and give you a 10 out of 10.
we got two dollars good R Kelly sneaker
heater into Xbox I'm sorry I'm just
trying to make sure I don't miss these
go
Spider-Man I ain't gonna lie it saved it
in that handheld I want to see more and
more about the handheld I was not
expecting Sony to come with more
Hardware these dudes are doing a
handheld they're doing VR they're doing
the the I mean and these dudes ain't got
the money that Microsoft got so here's
another thing my expectation for
Microsoft is even greater now if these
dudes are able to deliver VR in handheld
Microsoft what's your excuse I want to
see an Xbox handheld I still want my VR
that they promised yeah
already
huh you pre-ordered uh the raw gallon I
know I want to see Xbox
King King so we got uh we got five
dollar super traffic from mango
mcdickins when did dark city has become
an iron Lord with the hood yeah oh man
two dollars from DJ bird dos J dub stop
the cap we knew Spider-Man was gonna be
there four out of ten
Super Chat from uh uh g-mania one this
showcase is garbage the only thing that
makes this worth watching is King well
geez well I guess we ain't nothing we
just sitting here for nothing picking
them guys fight I was super trap from
various King told y'all this was
terrible King King I I gotta you know I
don't have a hat I got a beanie I gotta
take my beanie off for you okay like
lessons
um
shout out to over a thousand people in
the chat hit that like button do a
podcast every Sunday at 1pm yo I mean um
I came into this I came into this
thinking that it was gonna be a
hard-fought battle but The champ is weak
um
you know I went in there dusting them
off it's light work it's light work he
tried he tried it at the end to come but
we knew the left hook was coming so we
prepared for the left work yeah
Spiderman dude left hook you know in the
beginning they they threw the faint they
tried to tell you that it wasn't game
played and he tried to slip the gameplay
in it
um
yeah man it's over for these dudes they
call back they told me hold the line was
gonna be it's gonna be a problem it's
gonna break through next week next week
here man I'm still standing baby
um uh I'd like to give a shout out to
everybody that's been riding with me on
this on this wonderful journey of
smashing them down pushing them to the
back uh yo it's been fantastic but it's
a hard three this is a hard three points
three it's a hard three let me give you
three let me give you three Spiderman
gave me two because Spider-Man gave it
two points
um and they get one for showing up so
you wanna show everything on the show
was coming to Xbox uh so I can't give
them no no wins there somebody said
Snake Eater that's on Xbox
um
boy on fantasy oh yeah that's that we
saw that already I shouldn't have been
there you don't get no wins for showing
me the same dance moves you was doing
before
um
this this has been highly disappointed
we we waited two years man could you
imagine waiting two years for a shorty
and then you finally get the chance
trash
it's trash
ain't even about that life like that she
was telling you all that wild stuff yo
I'ma do this imma do that
this has been the most disappointing
PlayStation show I've ever seen and I
want y'all to go make a space
[Laughter]
we got royalty in the chat fighter super
chat from Lord kabatsu IOP Spidey two
looking like Grim hunt with Craven
hunting with family he went into regular
black suit for that Arc but game uh the
game making it symbiotic is as different
I I do I really like Spider-Man two
Super Chat from nobody175 so guys coming
from the Maddie stream what was this I
don't know man and then we got a uh you
know Mr ordinary 15 uh no Mr ordinary no
these X I don't know what that is
so uh definitely put the logo in the
chat for that for for my man's man put
them in there five dollars from black
Ronin 5 out of 10 showcase where's the
games a bunch of multi-plants and some
vrbs I know the media gonna cap for this
uh keep that energy though uh then we
got a member chat for raidenblade Xbox
don't need a handheld when everyone can
access our games like PS but Jada
this is a two years of no showcase L's
two dollars which are from just Spartan
13. he's not just Spartan one he's 13. I
used to pray for times like this yo yo
yo
oh my God
from Barry is bro two years bro I'm mad
for them
stop doubting the king Hold the Line
facts man I told you we had nothing to
worry about nothing you know what's next
y'all know what's next no we don't
Spiderman Spiderman versus Starfield
because you know that's the next
conversation hey they already moved
their date we gave a date son they don't
want they don't want the big this big
star filled outside September is is is
in the fall
we don't need to hold any line that was
uh what was that so yeah
our channel
from the from the PlayStation executive
absolutely why so why are you keeping
the energy because we know you know what
happened was we
we know if XBox showed a bunch of Indies
and a bunch of cat games you would be
going live it on Twitter right now so
explain yourself here's the thing right
because this whole FTC deal is going on
Sony had the sandbag and whole stuff
back you know everybody
you know what I'm saying that's all
right I forgot I forgot hold on yeah
because it's still going on they could
they couldn't go all the way to here you
guys you know and I'm gonna hold the
line with that with that response no but
it's it's a again you know it's a um
it's I gave it a 7 out of 10 show I
think the hardware and the Spider-Man I
mean unless you can't deny Spider-Man
biggest IP out there
um
this is opening the door for Microsoft
all right
you can't listen no no no no no no hold
on hold on at it because here's the
thing you you kind of can't get too
cocky because we've seen Xbox have a e3
show all to themselves right so all I
want to say is I hope Starfield is what
we think is going to be I hope it's a
great game and I hope they bring their a
game because this will put them back in
the game but
hmm it's it's Microsoft and it's Xbox so
I don't know I got to open the door just
giving them opportunity
Microsoft need to finish them
opportunity
we got to wrap this up soon because Carl
gotta go but Carl give your your I'm
just gonna say I thought it was a very
average show like a five six out of ten
uh Spider-Man's the only reason this
thing can get like a four out of ten for
me it got like two points by itself
yeah it was it was it was spooky in the
first half I would say a lot of Indie
show I didn't like the pacing I felt the
VR towards the end was a bit of a
mistake and then I the the problem I had
with it is that the bangers that they
had we knew because it's amazing as
final fantasies is an Amazing Spider-Man
is we kind of knew already so it's just
like I was expecting that we don't know
PlayStation exclusive AAA that's theirs
kind of thing and I didn't see that they
have some good games I gotta be honest
this is
probably one of the most disappointing
showcases for the two-year wait for the
two-year wait I was just like damn like
I can't I can't go no higher blade yeah
like where's the Stella blade they
already announced yeah so it's I agree
listen Kyle I can't deny like you guys
disappointment in the show all right I
can't say nothing about that uh all I
can say is Spider-Man 2
oh that's cool
so here's the thing I mean if they
didn't have if they didn't have
Spider-Man
yeah right
yeah because
if somebody I can always bring the heat
yeah let's save this yeah yeah no
literally literally because it looked
good but that's it I mean look Xbox the
ball is in your court I mean so much
Captain why about Captain not you oh
not you not j-dub oh what it's just the
energy
look you popping bottles I didn't think
they would have that level of consistent
wait look I love my Indies y'all know
that but it's just like it was just way
too much builder for this level of
weight of two years you've got to put
they had Microsoft on the ropes ready to
be knocked out they dropped red four
this everybody was like okay this is it
we're gonna see and I'm like
like that like that towards the end
but it was like the last call you really
got to go yeah I got to go I just gotta
say this to Congress that's something I
told y'all
been on fire there's nothing I could say
the PlayStation VR show up that that's
when the show was gonna fall oh you
literally called that and I was like I
hate him yeah
like you literally called them like oh
my God I got sauces too I think that was
the mistake I think like they should
have got that the pacing the pacing get
that in the beginning knocked that out
they had a couple of good things but it
just was spreaded like a lot in these a
lot of stuff and a lot of to your point
King a lot of you know not gameplay
everything for everybody none of those
games that they showed that was going
for anybody that's going to be rated let
me read these super chats and then we'll
head out find out from lero I the master
if Microsoft did a showcase like this
y'all would be killing them that's your
family
they would have Spiderman Aaron
Greenberg showed up wearing the hold the
line share the Xbox Show No Cap it's a
seven without showing games that Sony uh
Pony clown was a was a a six out of ten
I've got a member chat from primatic ego
Starfield is uh a single player Bethesda
game one was the last single player but
there's the game that didn't slap I'll
wait by the way stop comparing
completely different kind of games that
we saw so I'm gonna be honest then we
got a five dollar super trap from JD
gamer Ryan knows how to talk about
surprising at a lightly but this is what
the new Ryan rigmund can deliver
Microsoft they can keep it Microsoft my
first confirmed they found the appeal to
the CMA okay
first off I want to thank everyone
coming here we have 620 likes over a
thousand people in the chat you know if
you don't sub we do a podcast every
Sunday at 1pm called the iron Lords
podcast uh this this week's gonna be
crazy I know we're gonna talk about this
week crazy but I appreciate everyone
coming through here I'ma send you guys
to Kofi go over there to Kofi man I'm
only doing the attic show right now
everybody that came through and I told
you how to hold the line thank you for
holding the line I do appreciate that I
do appreciate y'all sticking there and
believing what I said and if y'all knew
what I said there's nothing to fear
because they only had Spider-Man this
year
games and it's gonna come with that
PlayStation VR crap and they was going
to do that little handheld we knew that
it was a slicing controller that was
split into the side to put a screen in
the middle we are live right now
Microsoft is gonna come out and do that
show that show is going to be an 8 out
of ten They're Gonna Knock these dudes
smooth out cold fantastic stuff love you
guys I love everybody
they showed a movie on a game showcase
that's right yeah I did not like that I
did not like that I'll be honest I did
not like that so y'all like the shirt it
was a PlayStation shirt Hold the Line
guys I appreciate everyone for coming
through you guys really pulled up like I
said I'm gonna send you guys to uh Kofi
go in there show them some love man tell
them IOP sent you and tell them not to
come not to forget that IOP sent you so
let me talk to you guys are up in here
that was love